[Music]
trying to figure out how to keep your
flow alive during the winter months here
are five drills that work even when
you're spinning inside Drex here from
Drex Factor Poise sharing with you the
love of pois spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today
it's cold out where I am and I imagine
it is for a lot of you all watching so I
want to share with you my favorite five
py drills to do inside when the weather
outside is frightful but before we Dive
In just want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro ter light
toys spinballs and Ultra poy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible you can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- business friend of the channel
Becca Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so the vast majority of Earth's
population is in the Northern Hemisphere
and right now the northern hemisphere is
in the middle of winter DC just had its
first snow day in four years when we got
dumped on by a whole 5 Ines of snow and
yes as a kid who grew up in Colorado it
does make me die a little bit inside
when I say those words out loud but it
also means that a lot of us are stuck
indoors when we want to flow and that
means we're spinning in some pretty
cramped qu ERS so how exactly can we
keep our flow going through the winter
and still manage to grow our skill set
fam I got you so today I'm going to
share with you five of my favorite
drills that can be done inside of a
really small space stuff that is going
to help you such that when you are able
to explore all that wonderful space
outside when things finally warm up that
well you're going to be in a position
where you have all of these awesome
skills so under your belt that you're
going to be able to wow all the people
around you starting with
with drill number one timing and
Direction so just to clarify what I mean
by timing and Direction here is that
you're just going to take your hands
without the PO in them and work them
through all of the different modes of
timing and direction we already know
that there's essentially something like
a circle of fifths that works with pois
spinning such that you can go back and
forth between two different combinations
of timing and Direction by looking for
the transition points top and bottom as
well as side to side this actually
carries with it the benefit that you can
perform this exercise without engaging
the poy at all this is really helpful if
you happen to be in a space where
there's a lot of delicate things around
and you want to be able to get some good
ideas for po transitions in your head
without necessarily having to risk
damaging anything around you and as
basic as this drill is it's really
important I don't know that I've ever
encountered something in pois spinning
period where I didn't need to have some
form of this information plus which the
more comfortable you get with being able
to just get your hands moving in the
different modes and switching between
them the easier it's going to be when
you actually do engage the PO in this
process sure it may seem a little boring
and basic by po standards but this is
something you should really revisit
frequently not just because it's going
to help with your muscle memory but also
because you'll be surprised by how many
different types of tricks that this
winds up being relevant for and speaking
of basic an exercise I've been giving a
lot of my students these past few months
because it turns out to be oddly
powerful is exercise number two pendulum
based Transitions okay so this one does
actually have a backstory I have a
private lesson student who primarily
works as a performer which means that
most of the time she's working with
those types of programmable LED po that
come in those long tubes which also
means that they're terrible fit for
stalls and so much of how we think about
transitions with po centers around
stalls and together we made a really
fascinating Discovery namely that when
you perform trans transitions with
pendulums they work just as well with
traditional say sock or contact poy as
they do with those LED POI the
transitions wind up looking seamless
either way so I developed an exercise
for this student that turned out to be
so powerful that I also then applied it
to many of my other students and lo and
behold it just turns out to be an
incredible drill the idea is really
simple just use pendulums to go back and
forth between together same and together
opposites in wall plane and yet you'd be
surprised by how challenging this one
winds up being for a lot of Po Spinners
even those that think they're quite
experienced may not have the kind of
nuance of movement necessary already
under their belt in order to get back
and forth between these two places so
try this one out and see what you learn
in the process but in the meantime
speaking of
stalls drill number three the stall
box so by now it is probably no secret
that I'm a big fan of conceptualizing
stalls as essentially being those places
where we get the PO to land in the
corners of a box that sit around the
circle that the poy head is going around
as it spins and personally I think that
this is one of the best ways to get down
all the Stalls the idea here is that you
just go side by side of the Box tracing
your way all the way around it not only
does this help you get down each and
every one of the Stalls and gives you a
physical conception of what's supposed
to be happening at each of those points
it also gives you a way to move around
and drill all of them in a highly
systematized fashion and bonus points
you can then apply this very same idea
to performing the stall box in all the
different timing and Direction modes to
really really get down those stalls no
matter how you happen to be spinning
your poy whether it be performing this
in together
[Music]
same together
opposite split time
opposites
or split Time same
[Music]
direction seriously this is a really
really powerful drill and I would highly
highly highly encourage you all to
explore it but it does come with a
little caveat because all of those
stalls are what I would refer to as ins
spin stalls and to every ins spin there
is drill number four anti-spin
stalls all right so this one's a little
bit more challenging to visualize but
fundamentally it's exactly the same idea
as the stall box we're going back and
forth between different positions where
we do our stalls and doing so in a
systematized fashion in this case though
we're just picking each individual petal
of the flower one by one in performing
both of the Stalls that occur there and
of course just like we had for our
original stall box there is a version of
this that involves performing this drill
in each and every timing IND Direction
mode again we can do this together
[Music]
[Applause]
same as well as together
[Music]
opposite and split time
opposites
and split Time same
[Music]
[Applause]
direction all right so before I share
with you my final pick for a great drill
to do indoors in a small area I do have
a favor to ask if you come this far I'm
hoping that it means that you're really
into py Trix and if so guess what I make
lots of videos about those so we can
help us both out by having you subscribe
to the channel that way you know right
when I drop a new video and I have
wonderful new eyeballs that I can give
those videos to so please hit that
subscribe button please and thank you
and now for my final pick for five
awesome drills that you can do indoors
during the winter we arrive at drill
number one playing control in
meteors yeah so I just like jumped way
ahead on the skill difficulty level
there didn't I so the idea behind this
one is relatively simple to explain too
whenever we perform one-handed
butterflies we're having to achieve some
degree of separation between the planes
of our two po even as they happen to be
spinning in the same hand in order to do
this we want a drill going back and
forth between having those planes
straight upright and having them more
out on a horizontal level and this
becomes really really important not just
for learning one-handed butterflies but
also everything from weaves to Supermans
and a whole bunch of other one-handed
moves as well it's also just a fun
little way of showing just how bizarre
POI can really be going from spinning
the POI in such a way they feel like
they're in butterfly to when we flatten
them down it feels more like they're
spinning in Split Time same direction
it's a really fun demonstration of how
strange po planes get in three
dimensions so I highly recommend this
one awesome so those were my picks for
five awesome py drills that you can do
indoors during the winter do you have
some favorite drills that you do when
the weather outside is frightful and you
don't have a lot of room to work in
leave me a comment and let me know what
they
[Music]
are this video would not be possible
were it not for my awesome supporters on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen over here right now uh
if you enjoy these videos and you'd like
to see more of them there's an easy way
that you can help make that happen and
that is you go over to
patreon.com factor pooy and sign up that
way I get to keep on making videos and
educating people like yourself all
across the world so everybody wins in
that situation go check it out please
and thank you and if you'd like more
stall boox goodness I also recently
uploaded a video on how you can use the
stall boox to add musicality to your
spinning by Drilling it with music I'm
going to go ahead and link to that video
down in the description as well as on
screen in the meantime thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon take care now peace